I was thinking back the last time I saw
you and we saw each other a woman of
worth and look at us I found a photo of
us oh my god look how much is that great
what lovely colors yeah we did good yeah
some parts it's great I did another
woman of worth about two days ago did
you yes and it was as it always is
incredibly moving amazing women yeah
um and I just want to say actually as
we're here you know in these days of
darkness and you read such
um you know war of of shootings of
killings of criticism of people being
pulled down all the time it's so great
to be in a room full of women
who are just giving something positive
to the world I love you know out of
empathy out of love out of
um courage and and commitment and it and
it's so it's so great to remind yourself
that yes there is goodness literally
goodness in the world so for the women
of work I love that yeah and that's why
I love you so much your energy and the
fact that you put this out there your
speech of the SAG Awards one of the
things that stuck to me is that you say
you have giggles and laughter when you
work with your actors so I'm assuming
that was the case with Harrison Ford oh
yeah that's so much fun very much so fun
but also serious commitment as well yeah
it's not just oh it's all a laugh you
know
um because it's all and that's the other
thing about Harrison and all of our
actors but you know Harrison is if you
like our leader
um
you know utterly professional
commitments as well of course it's time
for you know jokes and laughter you have
to have that you gotta yeah and that's
in your character Cara Cara did you see
Cara Cara we say Cara
she yeah she is badass but also she's
complicated a little bit because she
she's very calm and very high anxiety
situations and she's very vulnerable
there are moments where you see her face
kind of just go what am I going to do uh
is there a lot of comparisons to you to
Cara or Cara
yes I think yes I think there are I mean
I think Taylor a brilliant writer Taylor
Sheridan extraordinary writer
um very much tailors to his his writing
and to the people who are playing the
roles yeah so it is actually all
constructed around your strengths and
your complications and your weaknesses
and everything so
um inevitably you've sit you fit very
well into the character
um and I do feel that with Cara it's not
a it's not a reach for me to play her
you know yeah and that's one of the
things with Taylor is that he created
this franchise with Yellowstone talking
about family trees in the history and it
got me thinking I'm curious to know have
you ever looked into the past of your
family maybe on your mom or your dad's
side that you found something really
surprising or fascinating
um well I I you know I am I I'm a hybrid
if you like my um my father came from
Russia to England he was an immigrant my
mother was very very English you know
Old English family I ironically I know
more about my Russian side of the family
because they were sort of um you know
they were aristocratic level of Russian
Society no longer once they came to
England and my mum was very very working
class
but an old London family so I would be
very curious to find out about my
English side rather than my Russian side
that's so fascinating you've got to do
that one day we're all amazing yeah we
are there's something about that that is
true yeah and one of the things when you
watch Yellowstone I'm assuming you've
binge watched the show
yes I've seen some of it but I haven't
binge watched it no do you ever binge oh
yes I do yes
um I was I was nervous about committing
to Yellowstone because it's so bad
that's so much of it you know and it's
like when do I have a year to watch this
um uh but yes I I do I do sometimes
what's your favorite snack when you're
binging
oh an interesting question toast toasted
Marmite oh yes of course yeah and a lot
of people are binging right now Queen
which has been 15 years and I wanted to
know what does she mean to you
personally the fact that you've taken on
the role you've met her in In This
Moment well that that all was you know
obviously
you know meaningful for me but much more
than that was the fact that she has been
present in my life for my whole life
um and always constant and always there
and doing the same thing I would say
when I same handbag same hairdo you know
for my whole life and I and and my
sister and I always used to say to each
other God you know it's going to be so
hard when the queen dies because it'll
be in a way the end of our lives in a
way or the beginning of the end of our
Lives
um and indeed that's how it was it was
very and I think for it was a very
profound and uh moment for Britain I
think that the loss that the queen down
we of course we knew it was going to
come
uh sooner or later um
but it it was a it was a I think a
profound moment for the country
would you ever do the role again if it
were to come up
no no no no no no no I mean I did it and
I did a play in the theater about the
queen I did the audience in London and
in New York and the film and that was
enough really you know just sitting here
with you have you ever had a chance to
kind of sit back and reflect on
everything that you have done for Cinema
and the impact that you've had
no I no I I wouldn't find I wouldn't no
I don't reflect on that no I don't think
I've had anything back whatsoever oh my
gosh like you've done this you're so
incredible like the fact I'm just
sitting here thinking about everything
you've done and it's beautiful well I'm
very I all I can think of is I've been
extremely lucky that you know hugely
lucky to be in in this amazing piece of
work that I'm doing now I mean I'm I'm
so I I think oh my God I am so lucky
this is amazing
and um I can't wait to get back to it